all right now before we get started here
i want to thank the sponsor of this
video this video is brought to you by
vincero
teaming up with vincero again because i
will always champion the necessity
of a stylish timepiece when you make a
stylish and affordable such as they do
you have my curiosity
and my attention and they don't just
have watches they have bracelets wallets
blue light glasses we live in a world of
the now you know a lot of tvs monitors
phones just makes it all easier on your
eyes when you're in my case gaming for
days i was gonna say hours but we're
talking about me here so days also you
can see the reflection of the light my
glasses try not to look
and now it's the perfect time to shop
there if there's spring sale going on
right now for a limited time
up to 30 off their entire site click the
link below get yourself some nice
stylish gear also free shipping on
everything that's always nice what do i
tell you i'm here to save you money and
talk movies
and tv shows at video games it's a
multi-purpose channel here no codes to
enter the sales just on so again click
the link below get some new stylish gear
up to 30
off the entire store and thank you once
again to vincero for sponsoring this
video
i do appreciate it now
well it's a new movie what's this thing
called
[Music]
thunder force right worth knowing so
thunderforce is
kind of exactly what you think it's
gonna be when you hear oh it's the
guy who did tammy who's also married to
melissa mccarthy and melissa mccarthy
gets super powers and it's a comedy
yeah which to be fair the premise sounds
interesting
on paper until you're like it kind of
doesn't make any sense but okay it's
comedy
i know i'm not supposed to take it too
seriously so in the moments in this
video where i start sounding like i'm
taking it too seriously no i just
you know would like something to flow so
the premise is
in the world people have gotten super
powers but not just anybody anybody
who's predispositioned to be a sociopath
has superpowers so now it's just a bunch
of super villains and there are no
superheroes it's funny because it's not
really what sociopath is not like people
who are
sociopaths sit around they're like i
just think of nefarious ways to hurt
people if only i had super powers
or means and opportunity i guarantee you
everyone out there all of us we know at
least one sociopath and they're probably
fine human beings but it's one of those
plot point things
like we only use 10 of our brain that's
but you know it makes for
fun movies i guess so here we are in
octavia spencer's character is like i'm
going to
create superheroes then melissa mccarthy
accidentally gives herself half of the
serum
it's you see it's going there and in the
movie it was going to be octavia spencer
was going to give herself
both of these serums and so she was
going to have super strength and
invisibility but melissa mccarthy's
character took one of the serums so now
her character
has super strength and octavia spencer
her character's invisibility
so which actually logistically makes
sense i mean if you're thinking of
mmo or video game team ups dps and a
rogue
that works i mean you probably want a
tank in there somewhere but yeah
dps and rogue is that my friend and i
would roll problem is it's a superhero
comedy
which is actually a boring superhero
movie that doesn't really make you laugh
that's pretty much tammy with
superpowers and it's a problem i see a
lot in these melissa mccarthy movies
it's just her character
she's the same character she just has a
new job in every movie sometimes she's a
boss sometimes she's a mom going back to
college
sometimes she's tammy now she's tammy
with superpowers and in terms of the
comedy there were a couple of
chuckles sure but really for the most
part the funniest one in this movie was
melissa leo when you have melissa
mccarthy doing her thing
ad libbing there's a joke for everything
it's just and the jokes go on forever
almost in that hey notice me kind of way
i just prefer melissa leo's
subtle responses to that that's what
gave me a chuckle in this movie
she's not in it much though so the rest
of the movie i was like it's just
it's just nonsense in the way that a lot
of these melissa mccarthy movies feel
it's
they feel like someone was like hey just
ad-lib you know do your thing
we'll fill it in later just ad-lib and
make jokes which doesn't always work for
a movie objectively if i pull myself out
of it and i imagine okay this lady was
like at a party at my house
she would be the funniest one in the
room absolutely i would beg her to come
back to the next party
she'd be hysterical can i imagine when
they're filming the entire crew the
camera crew they're just laughing their
asses off it's like oh dude
this lady's funny she's quick she's
sharp she just
has jokes about everything that said
it's not enough to keep a movie afloat
you still need
the plot to go somewhere you still need
good writing you still need characters
to give a about just a bummer
because
really good actors in this movie melissa
leo like i said octavia spencer jason
bateman
that's a guy with crab hands it's like
the world doesn't make sense at that
point you know you want a world where
all right all these super villains and
now we need to make superheroes but
people still interact with jason bateman
and his lobster hands like you know it's
just like like they're not there like no
it's fine
even though i know that you have lobs or
hands which means you have super powers
which means you are a super villain
you know just no one deals with it like
that which in the end is a comedy and it
would all be forgiven if the movie made
me laugh it really didn't had a couple
chuckles
usually with melissa leo couple with
melissa mccarthy i'm not gonna say i
didn't but it's just those chuckles you
know nothing where i was like that is
truly clever and if the movie's not
making you laugh it's just boring you to
tears
the 45 minutes of this movie is her
training to be a superhero
which to be fair a lot of superhero
movies are like that a lot of the origin
story ones the first half of the movie
is them training to be a hero only thing
is you're invested in them invested in
the world
when she's in the facility training to
be a superhero
i totally forgot that there were super
villains in this world i kind of forgot
the world we were dealing with heroes
just in this lab the entire time
forgot that there were super villains
out there at all you see a news clip and
you're like
oh yeah there are super villains
everywhere that's why this is happening
in the end the movie didn't do much for
me
i got a little bit of joy out of it
because i was like hey it's a new movie
it kind of feels good to just
watch a new movie and do a video on it
and you know maybe it's even unexpected
you know on fridays i'm going to do my
falcon the winter soldier thing
you didn't know this was coming today
did you this is what happens when i'm
sitting down like alright i feel like
i'd do a video today
what's new ah that's new
i guess that that wins i guess that's it
hey don't be pissed i'm the one who had
to watch it the movie wasn't funny
it wasn't exciting it wasn't interesting
i just kind of
nothing to it you know i'm going to
generously say i'm not going to remember
this one in t-minus one day yep
already forgot all right so thunder
thunder force right
i said t-minus i'm not making that up i
just said it a few minutes ago but here
i am
forgot it again pretty sure it's thunder
force though regardless have you seen
super tammy what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you